elle est bonne mais dans x men 1 mon
préféré c'est le hurleur mes mecs le
meilleur x men c'est professeur xavier
3,60 à vie à mes mecs lire dans les
pensées
c'est génial pour cent cinquante mille
euros attention dans quelle discipline
l'athlète sur la perche garder la fin ça
fait 27 fois que vous gagnez la miction
en 27 mois
non non non je pense que lire dans les
pensées des gens c'est plus cher que de
choses ça vous plaît tout ce que je vous
ai préparé vous en voulez peut-être bon
c'est gentil mais en tout cas c'est très
bon
c'était des yeux il n'a jamais su
cuisine est sûre il a dû lire dans ses
pensées
il entend potec libyenne il faudrait
surtout pas qu'il entende que je trompé
que son meilleur pote oups un jour il
faudra quand même que je lui dise qu'il
a été adopté
par contre magnéto le magnétisme et tout
ça c'est stylé
attend même le magnétisme depuis quand
est-il est d'accord bon pour toi m'at il
faut nuls qui est bien alors le fauve à
ces mois ci la meuf qui changent
d'apparence mystique mais parce que je
suis vraiment vous êtes rencontrés loide
moi aussi oui ça va tu as l'air bizarre
à amman ans parce que je ne vois mon ex
au fond là c'est un hasard c'est pour ça
son x merde c'est ça son style de fille
mais j'ai aucune chose bon en même temps
ça fait six mois que j'ai pas baiser
donc mr jazz naturel et ça va passer et
sinon tu écoutes moi comme musique
ouais asie le truc vachement bien avec
le faux mois tourmag tornade pas tant la
demande
mais il y en a un carré manchot mais
vraiment vraiment un grand x men brin
wii se délecter griffe
oui mais ouf leur quête sa taille là
même dont super con excusez moi excusez
moi vous voyez qui on parle wolverine
voilà testament si vous le verrez dans
mais lui on peut le dire c'est le plus
lui il est bien nous on aime beaucoup
wolverine se parler de de haendel end je
n ose mettre au tas d'idées griffe dont
on disait des dlc pour ça aw angels
désolé les gars merci monsieur jackman à
la science et à
incroyable mais vrai